foreign
time for Saturday night's press preview
as we check out Sunday's front pages and
tonight we'll see what's making
headlines for the journalist and author
Christina Patterson and the editor of
the Jewish Chronicle Jake Wallace
Simon's great to have you both with us
we'll speak in a moment after we've had
a look at the front pages that we have
already workers may be able to sue their
bosses if they are offended by customers
reports the Sunday Telegraph the Sunday
Express says the Prime Minister has six
months to sort what it calls the boat
crisis
while the male leads with their
exclusive investigation about more than
100 eco-activists planning to sabotage
the Grand National by gluing themselves
together to stop the race
The Observer reports of a national
Scandal as their investigation reveal
that some of Britain's most vulnerable
children have been moved to Care Homes
hundreds of miles away
according to the Sunday Times patients
waiting for life-changing surgery face
having operations canceled a second time
as more doctors strikes begin next week
while the mirror hears that the late
Entertainer Paul O'Grady gave his
friends one order for his funeral to
have a laugh
while the Daily Star turns its attention
to the tropical weather that's forecast
for Easter 24 degrees I believe that
when I see it
don't forget
the QR code you'll see on screen join a
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us discussing them and Christina
and Jake are here to do just that uh
good to see you this Saturday evening
um interestingly a lot of the papers uh
all splashing with different uh stories
tomorrow but let's start with this one
Christina it's on the front of the
Sunday Express saying that the Prime
Minister has just six months to sort out
the the boat crisis
yeah so this is according to some of his
aides who are not named in this context
the the idea being that uh of course
there are more always more people who
risk their lives on the small boats over
the summer and therefore if he doesn't
make progress in the next six months
then he's really high bound about where
he can hold the election which has to be
sometime next year it would have to be
um probably next Autumn so um you know
there's big pressure on him I mean I do
think I understand why Tories think this
is an issue I think it's much less of an
issue for many people in fact the polls
show it's less of an issue than than
Tory think it is but in certain
constituencies or certain areas like the
so-called red wall it is regarded as a
big issue and one of the reasons it's
regarded as the big big issue is to do
with perceptions of fairness and um the
sense that people are playing system by
uh by paying
um people's modelers to Buck the system
and come here here and I understand that
sense of unfairness I think it is an
unfair system I think it was unwise of
uh Rishi sunak to make stop the boats
such a central part of his promise to
the electorate because nobody else has
managed to do this and of course it's
possible he'll make progress it's
possible that they will manage to start
getting people's Rwanda I don't approve
of that policy but it's possible they'll
succeed but it's also pretty possible
that they won't succeed in fact the
likelihood is that they won't succeed in
which case he really has created a rod
for his back but um you know they they
clearly feel they you know Rishi sunak
is apparently working very hard
personally on this so we'll have to see
what happens uh and it's the same story
in more detail inside the Sunday Express
uh Jake what what's your take on this
I think it shows as the Sunday Express
reports that Richardson is up for it he
thinks he can win the next election he's
staking his reputation and the uh
possible success in the next poll on
this issue uh telling the public very
very okay that he's going to be the man
to sort it out after previous prime
ministers have failed and judge him by
his actions and you can see he's going
all out in this attempt in terms of the
Rwanda policy but also in terms of
backing It Up by trying to counter the
European Court of Human Rights uh
ability to interfere with the
legislation that he's trying to rule out
um and now these AIDS are piling
pressure on him by saying that he's only
got six months to prove it because if we
have a summer uh obviously in the summer
there's a peak of people trying to cross
because of the good weather if his
policies don't work this summer then
he'll be more likely to be forced to
call an election in May for fear of a
second summer of chaos with lots of
migrants coming over and then uh the
last opportunity to have an election
will be October following two summers of
failed policies he would be he would be
toast
um so he definitely is risking
everything on this policy
um and I guess he's thinking to himself
who dares wins and of course Christina
he does have a um a more pressing uh
deadline doesn't he the the local
elections are coming up next month and
we've already seen sort of campaigning
around potholes to Crime to to sewage
and I guess a lot of that is targeted at
those elections and and voters going to
The Ballot Box in in parts of the
country
yes well good luck with them in terms of
campaigning on sewage because what the
Tories have done over 13 years has
absolutely flood the British waterways
with sewage I mean our sewage levels in
our rivers and oceans are kind of you
know developing World levels it is an
utter disgrace so if they could sort
that out that would be great but I would
say their chances are sorting that out
by the next election are pretty much
zero and I can't imagine why they've put
this as an issue since it's entirely
their fault they created this problem
but you're right that these elections
will be important I think it's I think
it's I mean I don't think the Tories
will do well in them but it is also true
that sunac has studied the ship after
the absolute chaos of of Liz truss and
Boris Johnson and let's not forget that
many people are paying much higher
mortgages as a result of Liz truss's
crazy experiment with the British people
and and you know the whole economy is
still re feeling from that so I think
you know they can pick issues like
potholes if they like but the real issue
will be the economy and the cost of
living crisis and the fact is and I
think any of us whenever we go to a
supermarket or a restaurant or almost
anywhere the price of everything has
gone up so much it's quite breathtaking
and many people are really really
struggling and people who are struggling
do not vote for incumbent governments
who have created or partly created this
situation yeah and of course another big
issue for the prime minister is the the
NHS and the ongoing strikes it's covered
on the front of the Sunday Times Jake
their headline A New Nightmare for
patients as strikes return
that's right I find this strike story
extremely uh troubling there seems to be
no end to it I mean you can understand
people striking in um in sectors where
people's lives are not at risk but
doctors going on strike you know 320 000
appointments have already been lost to
strikes so far in this current wave and
the junior doctors are going to go on
strike again after the bank holiday for
a further four days uh and the Sunday
time story just over there uh cites two
brief case studies one of a 13 year old
girl who's been waiting for spinal
surgery due to have it in two weeks time
and now it's been postponed because of
the strikes to June and then another man
he's a father of two waiting to get
married but needs to have open heart
surgery it had to be his wedding had to
be canceled three times because of the
strikes delaying um his appointments
again and again and we all know people
in our Lives who are waiting for
operations or wedding waiting for
medical uh treatment and who had to put
up with delays as a result of the
strikes and sometimes it people are
getting iller and iller and more and
more desperate for medical help and
these strikes it seems to me are very
immoral I I can't see why the Army and
the police are banned from striking
because of their jobs being so vital to
National Security and yet doctors are
allowed to go on strike regardless of
people's well-being well nurses went on
strike as well Christina didn't they
um and they have been given a better
deal it's it's not been voted on yet
it's said to be on on something of a
knife edge but it does show that that
strikes do work
strikes do work and um and I have
sympathy for all health workers actually
and both doctors and let's you know we
call them Junior doctors many of these
so-called Junior doctors are actually
you know they're they're not 22 year
olds you know some of them have been
working for a decade more than a decade
in the NHS and for many of them pay is
extremely low where I I agree with Jake
is that or he hasn't exactly said this
but it seems to me that I think the most
the all the polls showed that support
for the nurses was very high and and the
nurses actually made what was you know
probably well clearly
um and excessively optimistic bid I
think they were asking for 16 pay rise
or something which clearly wasn't going
to happen and hasn't happened in terms
of the offer but my understanding is
that Junior doctors that go oh asking
for something like 35 which is clearly
ridiculous and they I think refused to
engage in discussions last time round so
I do think that the uh the the junior
doctors have been there is a militant
subset that have taken over which um is
kind of complicating the whole thing
because there is enormous sympathy but
you know you have to you have to kind of
Bear in mind as Jake says that these are
people's lives that are at stake and
although NHS trust as far as possible
are providing cover that is only as far
as possible they like you it is people
will die as a result of this people will
experience extreme pain those those
heartbreaking examples that Jake just
gave I think you have to be very very
very careful before you strike When
people's lives are at risk and I'm not
exactly sure that this current crop of
Duty doctors and their leaders are being
careful enough
okay let's move on to politics in the
states then uh also on the front of the
Sunny Times uh Jake
um Donald Trump indicted uh this week
um how's his base reacted
well Trump is characteristically framing
this as an attempt by the Democrats to
bring him down because they know that
he's the biggest threat and likely to
win the next election in his in his um
in his View and his base seem to be
energized by this and this is the thing
about Trump that he he just sucks in any
kind of publicity whether it's good or
bad and turns it into a win for him in
some way either he's pumping himself up
if it's good publicity or if it's
negative honesty he's framing it as some
kind of attempt to bring him down by
this uh the forces of darkness and his
base laps it up and this latest route
over whether he's going to allow himself
to be put into handcuffs or not I wasn't
aware that people had to get permission
to be handcuffed by the police but
nonetheless he's going to apparently
refuse I mean this is just another
element of theater isn't it that's going
to just speak to people who might vote
for him be energized for him and
reinforce his sense of being the being
the man who can drain the swamp who can
be this anti-establishment character
fighting the machine and so it strikes
me that you know with Trump there's no
such thing as bad publicity yeah of
course the charges against him still
under seal uh we'll learn more next week
but that could change opinions I guess
um Christina I know you'll want to talk
about this we'll save it till next hour
if you don't mind we're out of time but
thank you both for the moment coming up
after the break plenty more from the
papers including the Sunday Times his
interview with secure starmer who's
called for an end to what he calls the
toxic debate over transgender rights uh
don't go anywhere
thank you
[Music]
lots more to discuss with Christina and
Jake front page of the Sunday Telegraph
Christina I mean these statistics are
all for aren't they those under the age
of 18 are now three times as likely as
adults to face year-long Waits For Help
from Community Health Services more than
12 000 children having dangerous weights
to get help on the NHS
I mean it's just heartbreaking really
really heartbreaking I I wrote a big
piece recently for the standard times
about my sister's
um schizophrenia which had a big effect
on our family and well obviously most of
all on her and had a very big response
from people who had heartbreaking
stories of their own and when my sister
was a child the mental health provision
was not great it was post Thatcher and
the whole idea of care in the community
which essentially meant family care for
people and I mean there was some
psychiatric help but really not very
much and what is absolutely
heartbreaking is that all these years on
not only have we not got any better at
looking after Children's Mental Health
needs but we are clearly so much worse
the state of our NHS at the moment is is
really lamentable and I think that even
I mean there's the issue of children
having suffered under lockdown who have
serious serious mental health and
physical issues now for many but there's
also the issue that apparently life
expectancy has dropped by three years
which is one of the reasons that they
haven't brought the pension uh the rise
in the pension age forward in the way
that they might have done so you know we
are in a bad state of health in this
country and the state of our NHS
woefully underfunded is really not
helping yeah and it is heartbreaking as
you say when it comes especially to to
children and the lockdown generation is
the the telegraph is calling them um
let's move on to the Sunday Times uh
secure style was given the paper an
interview uh including questions about
whether or not he's got a grip on on the
trans issue Jake
that's right finally kirstama has uh has
come out with a view on what a woman is
and he seems to have come to the same
conclusion as pretty much everybody else
knew already which is that a woman is is
not a man uh there was a a bit of a
Fluff a sort of kerfuffle about this
back in the beginning of the year where
he was asked I think by Nick Ferrari on
LBC to say what a woman was he wasn't
able to come up with an answer well now
he's had a good think about it and has
come up with one
um this is a very straight it's weird
you know 2023 that that it's such a
piece of news that somebody can say what
a woman is
um the the story he goes on to point out
that only 0.5 of a percent of the
British population
um identify as a gender that's different
to the one in which they were born
um and it's strange that that the sort
of ideology that accompanies that
um is something that's become so uh it's
so taboo to disagree with it if you see
what I mean I think most people feel
that you know you're the sex that you're
born with and the idea of being born
into the wrong body is a bit is a bit
odd so um I think Chris armor now is
pitching himself firmly in the
mainstream finally I think a lot of
people both inside the labor party in
the country would be breathing a sigh of
relief about that yeah
um
um and let's talk uh briefly about this
in the express Christina Sarah's mum
back's new child abuse law
yes I mean to be honest Sarah's mum in
this particular particular context is a
bit of a red herring this is the mother
is Sarah Payne who uh was of course
um abused and uh murdered by Roy uh
Whiting and um as a result of her
campaigning she um it was agreed that
the little would be changed so that
people would know whether someone they
knew had would have the right to know
whether someone they knew had committed
pedophilia
um so you know that was that was
certainly a success for her but this
particular new law that Zoella bravaman
is pushing is about mandatory reporting
for people if they suspect there is
child abuse going on in schools and
other institutions and if you look at
what happened in for example the
Catholic church and what has emerged in
all kinds of children's homes and
institutions and indeed in relation to
Jimmy settle at the BBC then clearly uh
this sounds sensible because the idea
that anyone would suspect that sexual
abuse was going on of children and not
report it is is so deeply deeply
shocking but also has happened a lot in
this country and around the world so
this to me sounds like like progress
okay and um just 20 seconds to tell us
about this story Jake you talked about
Trump before the break and you can talk
about uh cows trumping uh now
well apparently cows emissions from cows
are responsible for 14
of our gases that harm the environment
and the government's going to force them
to eat stuff that's going to make them
emit less gas apparently they mainly let
out through through burping uh contrary
to public uh kind of perception ah
excellent we've all learned something
tonight thank you very much for that um
we'll speak to you again in half an hour